yeah and there's this talent pool that's
coming up that's blowing my [ __ ] mind
yeah I think that's the thing that I
mean I think you hit it on the head
because of the internet and you know you
to now Instagram you know I think it's
literally anything that you want to
learn is accessible just by like typing
it up and I think with the younger
generation these kids that are growing
up but I think kids are naturally
they're just sponges you know and I mean
like they can learn anything and and the
kids are the ones that are the fearless
one so they're gonna try that crazy air
flare thing fall on their head and get
them you know if I try that falling I'm
done dude like there's no way I'm even
attempting that again but I think with
combining you know the resources of
YouTube the Internet with these kids
that are just down to learn and be
sponges they are getting information
faster more accessible and they could
look up other people who do it
differently so they have this variety
now of just offering and then they can
now take it into a dance studio because
with us too we didn't have any dance
city we're doing it in our garage in our
living room floor so you know we just
have limited space limited resources but
now I think you know with Internet what
it is people are becoming super talented
at a very young age therefore because I
think even you know during the time when
I was growing up there were child
prodigies but it was that one kid in
that one area and then he was just like
so famous but now my kid David like he
was yes the dude you know I remember
watching kid David I like who the [ __ ]
is this guy he's super [ __ ] young but
there's a not not to take away from kid
David but there's a lot of kid David's
now like were young people that are on
his level of talent and he at the time
like I just remember watching him like
this [ __ ] guy's crazy yeah like it's
unreal yeah it's just the dancing is
such a crazy thing I I think like the
one of the things to that I do see a lot
though specifically from I you know I
talk to a lot of dancers they they kind
of see this thing where kids will
emulate a lot but they're not getting
their own style and that's also the the
positive and the detriment of it right
so I see a lot of kids who I'm like I
know that dance because I saw Mike do
that yeah
I saw Ben do that or I saw [ __ ] Phil
do this I'm like yeah you're just like a
kind of like a damn what the [ __ ]
somebody getting arrested right now
[ __ ] up my podcast rely on these
streets of Glendale yeah some Armenian
dude is robbing some poor little Korean
lady but but yeah they be kind of like
they sample a lot which is great I think
as a great foundation I just sometimes
see a lot of stuff repetitive where
they're not doing their own yeah thing
right so I think that's the cool part
where you get to see somebody who's yeah
you dance but you don't dance you know
what I mean so I kind of start to wonder
like you know when [ __ ] if this
cop doesn't arrest this fool just going
around a circle like a cartoon
characters you know yeah but I feel like
sometimes like I see some of these
dancers and I'll like kind of glaze over
it it's it's like the same concept with
YouTube a lot of people had the same
content because people are picking what
everybody else does but they're not
improving on it yeah and I see that
sometimes with dance yeah you know I
think that that's that's so funny
because I think yeah back in the day you
you would catch something you would see
somebody do something and like more than
likely you're not gonna have it
accessible on this you know portable
device readers watch the crap out of it
and learn it to the T you might have
seen it once or twice and then you take
it home and then you you do what you
think it was yeah cuz that's how anyone
learns you're gonna see somebody do
something it's like I want to learn that
and then you learn it the way that you
think it's done and a lot of I think a
lot of originality from back in the day
came from kind of almost by mistake you
know you you kind of doing something in
a way that you think it's supposed to be
done but you actually tweak it some
somehow different cuz you you're your
own person you're not gonna be able to
literally regurgitate something you saw
once and then you know someone will see
sorry oh that's that's an interesting
take like on a windmill like you know
like now you're doing it with like your
arms tucked in like what's that
you know like was like alright just that
that's how you supposed to do it you
know and then like people take that and
it just evolves you know what I mean but
I think yeah you said it with with kids
now you know they'll see something and
they you know again it starts with
wanting to emulate but because
it's so easily I can rewind it as much
as I want to be like where did his left
hand go at that time or whatever it they
literally can become you know yeah
literally mimics something and I think
you know that's that's something that
and I don't think you can fault anybody
for that because they they're just
having fun they're doing it because it's
fun but like I think as you know people
who are you know kind of in have been in
this game I think that's why people
emphasize be original you know it's okay
to it's okay to start somewhere and and
and even learn something the way that it
was done from somebody but then take
that and then like inject yourself into
it and see how you can evolve because
the hard part is like I I even see this
with music or any type of art nowadays
you know back in the day if you were a
[ __ ] biter you got called out for a
[ __ ] yeah and people are like well let
let it like this is the phrase I hate
the most
it isn't let them just live like what
the [ __ ] does that mean like you're we
have two separate definitions of let him
just I understand well let him just let
let them have fun but the problem with
that is that when it comes to art is
that when you steal somebody's art
you're actually stealing a piece of
their originality and their soul you
know like the the point and the sweat
and tears that it took for them to get
this thing you didn't have to go through
that fire to get to where they're at and
you just took it yeah now mind you you
took it and you gave credit that's a
completely different story because I
know it's like some people go well why
do they need credit they just did it for
the art right no but you're taking a
piece of they're harder [ __ ] work
yeah and even just saying hey I learned
it from this guy it makes them feel
better because it shows that what they
did wasn't for not right because let's
say you did something and then you got
more famous off of what they created
that's great for you but you're not
giving respect words do and that's
that's the part of the art there's a
little bit of narcissism to it you know
like you can't deny that [ __ ] yeah there
you want to be recognized for your
[ __ ] hard work and that's anybody and
everybody yeah so when people allow this
whole biting thing and they're just like
oh well it's okay like wow you know a
lot of people who do that [ __ ] are also
people or [ __ ] talentless they go oh
biting is okay cuz you want it you want
it to be okay so you could [ __ ] do it
too and that's what I hate it's like pay
homage and pay for [ __ ] respect yeah
I totally agree
I think this is like a great topic
because I think people have opinions on
that right like what is what is biting
and what is inspiration and and all of
that and I think there's there's a fine
line there but just what you said
crediting the people that you know have
taught you or that you're inspired by
and and I think it doesn't always even
have to be like oh this person
personally taught me he's like no I
watched this person on YouTube where I
saw this here and then I thought that
was dope and so like shout out blah blah
blah for doing whatever and you know
this is where I've been inspired by and
then you take it somewhere else and so I
think the the crediting side is
definitely you know like yeah that's
very important in terms of because I
think at the end of the day yeah you're
making someone who created it or maybe
kind of you know was a part of the
origination or something like feel
better it's like yes that's what's up
man you shouted me out like thank you
you know and I think a lot of people
that are kind of in the space that kind
of have grown up through the
pre-internet and we're kind of doing it
on that garage kid level and then
internet popped up and we like you know
like I would say I'm from that
generation cuz yeah I was I was doing
this before YouTube in any of that and
then I kind of caught up late to all
this stuff I'm like what is this YouTube
thing that everybody's talking about
yo this there's a lot of stuff out there
and you know even from the days from
Jabbawockeez and like you know there was
there were crews like in in Asia like
Philippines and stuff that were
literally ripping oh I saw that she the
masks and the whole thing routine and
the [ __ ] and and and and yeah it was it
like it pissed it pissed people off
because it's like you know these guys
are literally on TV in the Philippines
like yeah
get getting paid off of this stuff and
Jabbawockeez still over here trying to
figure it out trying to make you know so
I think in those in that context that
whole thing was put on but finding a
biter that's what you are Patong in a
biter you piece of [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] I swear to god I [ __ ]
kill you [ __ ] son of a beech I
started I remember when I should came
out I was like what uh [ __ ] at least let
me try let me try to make it some like
even a little bit they didn't even try
yeah they literally took it and they
were making money off of your guys's
hard work and that [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
irritating yeah you know and there were
certain comments they're like well
they're doing it just as good so what's
the problem I was like people who say
that are ones who want to steal and be
okay with it do you want to be able to
steal and say like well they did it too
because if you were somebody who had
just a little bit of just decency he
would never write something like that
yeah because you wouldn't you wouldn't
know how hurtful it is to work that hard
in somebody to take your artistry that
[ __ ] is it's it's it's it sucks you know
when I was on YouTube there was this kid
back in the day I think he got I [ __ ]
roasted this kid like I literally he
literally took the the videos that I was
doing and just put it on his own channel
and just changed his name and I was like
those are my exact jokes I was like what
the [ __ ] yeah and I roast this guy he
deleted all those videos but there was a
couple of comets there like well he's
making people laugh what's the problem
and I'm like see and you are the exact
type of [ __ ] that I'm talking about like
no I'll be it when I had these videos
back in the day they were like failed
stand a bit so I just put it in blogs I
was like it might be funny to some
people I don't really know but at the
end of they still mine and even if you
gave me credit you still shouldn't use
it because he's making money off of my
work so as I was working this on a stand
up stage and it was bombing and I had to
go through that embarrassment and put it
on this video you know you're taking
you're making money off my work like
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
like I I know people some people might
think that's petty but it's not it's
hard work yeah I agree I agree and I
think that's the thing is I mean well at
least I mean not to say that it was good
or okay because he credited you but I
mean at least he didn't credit me oh he
didn't credit I found out yes not
defense they're like oh this guy's
stealing your [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I mean
again I think you know inspiration is is
taking something that that you dig that
you that you vibe with but you have to
flip it you have to inject something
else into it in order for it to be your
own thing because at the end of the day
I mean you know you can't reinvent the
wheel like 10 times over I mean it's
already there and everything's been done
already yeah any you know from you know
a joke to a dance move to
you know a song someone's gonna start
something and that is gonna like it's
gonna spin off into something else that
looks or sounds or kind of feels like
that but there's something different
about that and and I think that's what
art that's why arts beautiful because I
think you can see how something can
start somewhere and then evolve into
this and even if you look at you know
art movements in like painting and stuff
like that there was all these different
things that these artists were doing and
they would look at that and then they
would take that and go do something else
so that's why there's so many genres
from you know from you know visual arts
to music to you know comedy and all that
I think there's but that's the beauty of
it and it's dope to be able to see
something like dang that's tight I kind
of feels like this so it looks like that
but they took it here you know and then
it becomes this game that I feel like
keeps art going you know what I mean I
think that's what's dope about it yeah
you know just to just to clarify for
other people not everybody's gonna be
that person that's gonna be able to take
that and then evolve it into something
else I think that should be a goal and
there's a that's something that should
people should attempt like I think my
biggest issue is when you take it and
then you say that you didn't get it from
anywhere it's like oh [ __ ] talk about a
slap to the [ __ ] face you know what I
mean it's like if you're up there and
then people ask you go home I just
[ __ ] figured it out myself
yeah you [ __ ] did yeah you know give
credit where credit's due like oh no
people talk about Stan like you're right
especially in comedy I see similar
standard bits all the [ __ ] time all
the [ __ ] time all the same jokes
about marriage relationships whatever
but their twist is how they experienced
it in their relationship or how they
express that through their lens so yeah
it's technically the same joke but not
really at the same time and that's the
way that you innovated and you know some
people might have an argument where they
go okay well we'll give me an example
that indents this is my favorite example
like I see two three people that I know
that dance not the same but they kind of
had that same swag but it's same and
different right so is that kid schizo
and the and les twins mm-hmm they have a
similar vibe specifically the way they
dance the way they hit beats the way
they groove it's very similar right but
it's so [ __ ] different at the same
time yeah and I think that's where
people can see if you guys don't know
who these people are like in the dance
scene check it out and you'll see what I
mean like the groove is very similar but
they're completely different dancers and
that's an example of innovation and just
kind of having your own style to it that
kids get so [ __ ] insane yeah like
when I saw him dancers like who the [ __ ]
is this where's he from I'm not sure he
dances I think he dances in Vegas right
or something like that I think he's like
in the Michael Jackson show or some [ __ ]
like that but that [ __ ] in something
the twins were in the in the Michael
Jackson show too which is